[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so sullivan
heute gibt's im ramadan menü tag
gewartet die ramadan zeit ist unter
fastenmonat ramadan begonnen hat und
zwar möchte ich heute ein menü machen
mit köfte hackfleischbällchen in
formaten wurde und wie werden im ofen
überbacken und mit kartoffeln serviert
die kartoffeln sind wirklich genial weil
es so viel pech hatte kartoffeln sind
und die einen imbiss teamchef aber
irgendwie auch fragt kartoffeln geht es
um 2 9 prozent und vor allem könnt ihr
das rezept gut vorbereiten und dann eben
am abend zu werden
ich bleibe jetzt mal die flut hatten für
die köpfe brauche ich 500 freunde
hackfleisch eine zwiebel 1 teelöffel
getrocknete minze und soll nämlich einen
halben teelöffel kreuzkümmel und
fertigen pläne von chili etwas rapsöl
zum anbraten für die soße brauche ich
eine knoblauchzehe 1 esslöffel
tomatenmark eine doppel tomaten oder
drei reife tomaten ein und wird mit
zucker oder eine prise zucker den halben
teelöffel salz und einen teelöffel
oregano zum überbacken etwas käse ich
habe ich noch ein kilo kartoffeln dessen
festkochende und salz zu erfahren die
zwiebeln und den knoblauch zu ihr habe
ich jetzt schon fein gewürfelt
jetzt kann ich den tag fleisch zu essen
zubereiten ich mache es jetzt in der
küchenmaschine aber ihr könnt auch ganz
einfach mit den händen verkneten also
fleisch von bisher 1
und die masse muss man gut durchgeknetet
werden hier kommen jetzt die feine
zwiebelwürfel mit dazu dann auch die
gewürze
und jetzt kann alles gut verkneten
werden
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich die masse gut vermischt
und jetzt muss ich kleine feine welt und
daraus formen damit so ein bisschen
genauer wird und wie gleichmäßig groß
werden dem jetzt ein iphone einen
kleinen und wenn ihr die nicht ab machte
das eben auch mal in die hand nehmen
wird zusammenzurücken und seien kleine
bällchen formen und falls die
hackfleisch maße ein bisschen klebt sich
sein sollte könnte die hände auch ein
bisschen mit öl fett gesprächen habe ich
jetzt erstmal im kühlschrank gelagert
sind ein bisschen ruhen bevor er am rad
in der zwischenzeit kann ich aber auch
schon mal die kartoffeln zu bereiten
und da werde ich jetzt fehler kartoffeln
machen er eignet sich diese langen
kartoffeln wirklich sehr gut von der
form her aber ihr könnt wahrscheinlich
auch unternehmen
daneben stand so hübsch aus jetzt
braucht die zwei gegenstände die gleich
mir wichtig sind dass ich mir jetzt
meine träume mit 1 cm abstand
ihr könnt aber zum beispiel auch einen
kochlöffel nehmen braucht man eben
einfach auf beide seiten
wie können wir ein messer und können
jetzt die fächer schneiden und so könnte
eben durch diese zwar nicht ganz so
munter schneiden und die kartoffeln
fallen nicht auseinander
jetzt werden die hier etwa zwei
millimeter breit immer zugeschnitten
[Musik]
und damit ich mir am ende nicht den
finger schneidet richtig kartoffel und
schneider unter anderem seite her
nochmals die kartoffeln werden jetzt mit
öl bestrichen da nämlich jetzt auch
einfach toll ihr könnt aber zum beispiel
auch olivenöl benutzen
und wer möchte kann zum beispiel
zwischen diese fächer auch zum beispiel
noch reingehen
dann könnt ihr müsst ihr aber nicht
schmeckt aber wirklich besonders gut
oder auch verschiedene kräuter morath
wird wahrscheinlich beschreiben einlegen
jetzt noch mit salz und pfeffer tod
wirken und so kommen die kartoffeln
jetzt in den vorgeheizten backofen bei
200 30 grad ober unterhitze je nach
größe brauchen sie etwas 30 und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich mich jetzt schon
mal wieder um die hak wenzel kümmern
kleinen welten werden jetzt im heißen
fett angebraten und das habe ich jetzt
auch mittel hohe hitze erwärmt
da kommen wir werden von allen seiten
angebraten so was schönes und kostet
[Musik]
habe ich alle hackbällchen gebraten habe
ich hier noch ein bisschen resten
passierte einfach nur mal etwas rein und
könnt jetzt für die tomaten bloßes die
knoblauchzehe anbraten und auch
gleichzeitig das tomatenmark
anschließend kommen gleiche tomaten und
ratlose dass du und fallen viele gerade
habt könnt ihr auch frei zu tomaten
nehmen aber zutiefst an vom die
jahreszeit noch nicht mit regenreifen
lieber auf die tomaten aus der dose
zurück dass kurz aufkochen und geht dann
auch schon salz pfeffer zucker und aus
oregano dazu die soße daten frei
mittlerer stufe und paar minuten kochen
und ich kann die hak fans schon mal
nehmen und hier in diese kleinen
schälchen verteilung und zwar so dass
kleine kreise fans diesen auch für den
backofen geeignet und sind wirklich
super hübsch vor allem später zum
anrichten
so lange darf die tomatensoße jetzt
nicht ein kochen da sie ja noch im ofen
gebacken ist selbst verteidige
gleichmäßig über den küste ihr könnt das
ganze natürlich auch in wittstock von
anrichten
aber in diesem kleinen tontöpfen aber
diese gusseisernen fans finde ich
wirklich sehr versteckt vor allem weil
sonst brechen dabei haben wo man sie so
eben auch schön servieren kannst jetzt
kommen die pension in den vorgeheizten
backofen und war zu den kartoffeln dazu
ich stelle zur temperatur von 230 auf
200 grad runter da brauchen sie etwa 15
bis 20 minuten
achtet auf jeden fall auch die
tomatensoße sonst nämlich nicht dunkel
werden und kurz vorher gesträuch wir
dann mit dem geriebenen käse damit der
erwartungen verlaufen kann
das ganze natürlich ohne die
holzbrettchen und die pore des eisernen
rheins
[Musik]
jetzt ist alles fertig als kurzreise mit
farbe kommt natürlich auf die holzplatte
und die kartoffeln diesem weg nicht
wunderschön und dann kann das ganze so
serviert werden
was ich natürlich sehr genial findet das
ergebe denn der schmilzt richtig schön
deswegen nämlich dafür über überbacken
immer gerne kaskoschäden und das ist so
natürlich ein richtig tolles menü vor
allem sind vollkommen man wird richtig
was davon in fünf sie brauchen und auch
nichts dazu vielleicht mit kleinen und
salat noch dabei und natürlich ein
schönes bisher zum abschluss und fand
dieses rezept auch noch machen wollt und
geht auf die kinos lockte steht noch mal
ganz genau
jetzt fragt ihr wahrscheinlich was kann
ich denn ansonsten noch machen zum
ramadan zum start also zum fest
wahlabend da können die wirklich alles
zubereiten was er möchte schaut einfach
alle meine rezepte durch und schaut was
am besten für euch passt ich finde immer
ganz gut wenn man etwas hart wo man
nicht so lange in der küche stehen muss
was vielleicht auch gut vorbereiten kann
so wie hier mit dem hackbällchen die
können die wirklich morgen auch schon
vorbereiten und dann erst am abend leben
anpacken und mit in die soße und dann in
den backofen geben
also viel spaß beim nachmachen und bist
du nicht zumal fühlt ich glaube ich
sogleich noch fragen offen oder maskiert
[Musik]
und handel